[Música]
quisiera saber quiere sobre estudiantes
que me levanten la mano por favor
para ustedes es que me preparé
a ustedes se lo dedico
pues la verdad es que yo siempre pensé
cuando estaba ciao
la educación de calidad y abundante y va
a sacar adelante
y realmente así fue para mí pero en el
año de 1984
cuando yo terminé mis estudios no tuve
ningún problema
pero que ese momento no lleve en
consideración dos variables importantes
que iban a marcar el futuro de los
nuevos profesionales
son ustedes
uno de las universidades dejarán de
darnos la educación que nosotros no
tecnología se metiera produces
esto lo digo porque platicado con oliver
es a2 y les pregunto cómo te sentís
mal no es justo que
y haber estudiado 16 o 20 años para
encontrarlo en esta situación
algo está pasando
creo que usted es que es cierto esto no
es cierto
bueno
y decidí investigar
lo primero si era cierto que las
universidades andaban regando
cuida al pasado y esa casa que están
viendo ustedes esa casa que ustedes
también
en la escuela la primera escuela que se
produjo del estado
114 años tienes yo hice un par de años y
realmente la visité cuando entré me
sentía animado porque dije voy a
recordar algo y de repente cuando hablé
con los profesores me di cuenta de que
hay
y lo estaba pasando el alma
y lo mismo
la misma dictadura del profesor yo a mí
[Música]
libro 47 años algo macho y la educación
padre celestial qué pasó aquí
entonces dije no aquí hay algo malo pero
ojalá que no sea solo aquí voy a ir a la
secundaria
me voy a meter a los colegios de
secundaria a ver qué estaba pasando ahí
me encontré con lo siguiente los
profesores llegan corriendo a dar 45
minutos de una educación enlatada que el
ministerio educación la meten en un
programa de estudio
y ahí van corriendo corriendo
perdidos mediano simple 7 reprobación
pues qué sucede
y estos muchachos valera y desbalanceado
la única cosa que yo recuerdo que puede
ser rescatable de esta visita educación
media es crear duros colegios
que si están enseñando inglés bien muy
bien
eso sirve y la otra es que hay los
bachilleratos técnicos que están
los empresarios están ganando el
estandarte
pablos
voy para la universidad
me fui a meter alguna clase de oriente
la clase que yo serví cuando w
recién graduados 30 años atrás
y voy
y ya saben
lo mío no exactamente lo mismo me
encuentre
también más ecuaciones los mismos
polinomios las mismas derivadas siempre
me pregunten vivir aquí para aquí
pero como había que estudiarlo había que
estudiar entonces salir de allí donde 40
siete años
master y casi todo
pues bueno
después de que tuve mi visión y voy a
comparar esto con la vida real si está
parada de educación voy a mirar qué pasó
en la vida real y entonces ahí voy a
llamarles un vídeo para que que
realmente más o menos nos ubiquemos qué
pasó por ejemplo en 1903 en 1903
llamamos white nos regalan el sueño del
ser humano volar el avión
es dios
no fueron a ninguna universidad ninguno
de los dos
de sacar un mejor oeste y los aviones
van evolucionando e iniciar el
disponible elevarse más de la hélice a
la turbina de la turbina a los controles
automáticos piloto automático más altura
presurización
y ahí van caminando en el mundo en los
años llevándolos a la tecnología cada
vez más y más avanzada hasta el grado
que los aviones de hoy en día uno se
sube con mucha seguridad no tiene miedo
de volar en ellos y se da cuenta que ha
llegado a este
vuelan solos autonomía
seguridad
la vida real la que no nos enseñan en la
universidad porque viene usted escribe
era uno hacer como puntas un tablero de
un de un buey
tienes que puede ser en algún lado no
por qué
quedaron cerradas también
cuando las universidades se fundaron
siglo 12
tenían estipulado que era lo que podía
para dichas para hacer el bien para
formar líderes para buscar la verdad
tecnología ciencia innovación conservar
todo lo que es la naturaleza y las
culturas y lo hicieron bien no viene
aquí nada a darle duro a la universidad
lo hicieron bien
pero de repente
50 años aparecieron
y los locos que va a cambiar el punto
ante universidad
bill gates
el tercer año y no más universidad
no me siento dentro de ese cuadro
yo soy el innovador de estos profesores
no me están acompañando
a los seis meses
vamos ante la universidad que desee con
su posgrado no me interesa
herbert
haciendo un muro para que sus amigos se
costearán en el muro dijo no lo podía
ver la computadora no igual la
computadora
en seis veces el 80 por ciento la
universidad estaba pegada en su software
bueno si éstos abandonaron
estamos viendo porque abandonado
porque la universidad no es nido
porque la universidad no fomenta
investigación ni la creatividad
los profesores universitarios son muy
crueles
no todo
hay algunos como yo que de repente son
buena gente
pero pero bueno la verdad es que es
música
es estresante y que no pedí a nadie que
me es estresante la universidad
y luego sale uno de ahí voy buscando
trabajo
y se da cuenta que no devolviendo a
estos que abandonaron forman una
corriente y digo bueno que está bien
éstos están cálidos con fuera de serie
pero voy a terminar de preguntarme qué
están haciendo las universidades me voy
aa la onu a buscar ahí con la óptica es
la que se encarga de la propiedad
intelectual
una de cada 50 patentes proviene de las
universidades
entonces
y en ésta
desarrollando el mundo quién está
inventando los celulares
y todas esas cosas modernas que ustedes
están viendo de dónde viene
de la empresa privada
hay que aceptarlo
y lo digo para los estudiantes
hay que tener ojo que esté
porque por ahí se está yendo tu vida tus
años
concluyó en este o en este lado y digo
bueno ok algo está pasando en la
educación está paralizada y si está
paralizada porque está cortada una
cadena porque los eslabones se rompieron
porque primaria no casa con secundaria
porque secundaria no casa con
universidad porque la universidad no
casa con el gobierno el gobierno no casa
con la empresa privada la empresa
privada con la sociedad y no regresa a
la alimentación a mejorar el sistema
educativo porque no sabemos ni para
dónde vamos si supiéramos para donde
ahora por lo menos tendríamos una idea
este retorno no se está
y les digo algo si esa cadena sigue rota
y alguien no hace la unidad de santaella
ante esta cuarta revolución nuestra que
está volviendo estamos mente a la
tormenta ideal
no vean esos números mentirosos la
verdad es que viene un dominio
de la raza humana a través de una cuarta
revolución
y ese es el verdadero reto de las
universidades y el sistema educativo
evitar que venga esa cuarta revolución a
crear más desigualdad en este planeta
más ricos separados de los pobres las
máquinas controlando no a nosotros
porque ya no está
el estado
están y nosotros tenemos a actualizar
bueno que han hecho entonces los
sistemas del gobierno de la persona
revolución industrial que era aquella
que los mainframes
la computadora el internet los sensores
esa generó trabajo y crecieron muchos
los países que le dieron apoyo a sus
empresarios globalización comenzaron a
meternos sus productos
conquistaron los mercados levantaron su
paper pagar más impuestos crearon más
los trabajos en su país por eso nosotros
no podemos
no tenemos ese soporte de la tercera
y la cuarta revolución inicial es peor
porque se mete contigo se vete con tu
comida te va a quitar el trabajo y eso
es
complicado vean ustedes
hay dos dos tendencias una de los países
que ya están montados en la tercera
revolución que tienen todo
que van a seguir trabajando para mejorar
su pedido
y que nos siguen vendiendo todo lo que
compramos viene de sus países
vida eeuu japón pero hay otro grupo de
países
qué se le llama los países
desarrollados
y han optado por el pse por otro camino
es el limpio
y entonces estos países se preocupan por
que tengas tus hijos educación tu que
tengas trabajo salud tu jubilación
felicidad
entonces el propósito del gobierno ya no
es crear mucho muchas facilidades para
las empresas así crear facilidades para
el ser humano
vivo en personal y eso ha provocado que
ellos se disparen
a instant noruega australia
luisa
todos los países bajos
lleve una vida mejor que la de nosotros
y hay depósitos que podéis que son los
más ricos del mundo
porque nacieron rico
a qatar nadie le va a quitar su riqueza
y sigue siendo el más rico del mundo con
su gas y así caso contrario venezuela
pero podría desvelar
dice bill gates
y está cuarta revolución industrial nos
va a provocar 800.000 desempleados
ya se imaginan ustedes de qué países van
a ser los desempleados
a ver que el jueves
y de ahí van a venir los decepciones
para hacer probablemente tus hijos
tal vez esto pero probablemente sus
hijos
entonces el reto de las universidades y
los sistemas educativos cuales en este
momento no permitir que caigamos en más
desigualdad social
hay que educar a nuestros jóvenes ya
para que se adapten a ese conocimiento
hoy en día el que no conozca digital no
va a poder hacer nada
entonces las propuestas aquí rápidamente
reunir actores para crear un plan de
nación reformar planes de educación
totalmente cambiar los sistemas a un
lado nuevo sistema educativo
capacitar a un ejército de profesores
para que vayan ahí con las nuevas
tecnologías al último rincón de las
frases que extraigo hoy
working los imperios del futuro serán
los imperios de la mente imagines en el
44 using diciendo eso
hubo dueño
rodolfo perdomo dice alguna duda grande
de la universidad de entregar los
conocimientos
muchacho sólo para que vayan a trabajar
en el trabajo
la otra el rector de la universidad de
médico pero ramón de la fuente le
apuesta que la inteligencia artificial
va a venir a la educación y va a mandar
todo por la borda porque él dice que hay
200 años de obsolescencia
y
un pensamiento que es
no revolución aunque ustedes no
educación de calidad que revolución en
los sistemas y entremos a esa cuarta
revolución industrial el país corre el
riesgo de venirse abajo y peor aún
podemos ser cómplices de una esclavitud
de la mente
muchas gracias